The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So the
subject here is about
if you want to
understand interactions
between neutral objects.
So let's start in
a very basic way
by saying we have an atome
A, we have an atom B,
they are separated
by a distance R,
and we want to know what
is the force between them.
In a semiclassical
picture, we would
say that everything
is-- the force which
is responsible for that
must be the Coulomb force.
So the atom A and B
consists of charges,
so we should find
the charge density
in our system A, the
charge density of B,
we take the coulomb energy and
we integrate over the volume.
And this is how in e and
m, in the most general way,
you would to write down
the electrostatic energy
of a system.
You take all
charges, each charge
has a coulomb potential with
the other charge [INAUDIBLE]
indicate over everything.
But for objects
which are localized
and we can do
multiple expansion,
our objects are
neutral, neutral atom.
So therefore there
is no coulomb term,
and the next term is the dipole.
So therefore, starting
with classical physics,
we would find that the
interaction of those charge
density distributions one
for atom A, one for atom B,
should actually interact with
this Hamiltonian h prime.
OK, but now, if you
look at it classically,
we find that classically,
the expectation
value for the dipole operator
of each atom is zero.
But you will also
find-- if you said,
well, OK, that's what I
expect, because an atom
is in isotopic space.
How can it have a dipole moment?
But maybe, what could
happen is, if there
is a fluctuation of
a dipole moment here
and a fluctuation there and the
fluctuations are correlated,
then the two systems may
repel or attract each other.
So therefore, when we are
talking about fluctuations,
we are talking about expectation
values for d squared.
But also in classical
physics, this is exactly zero.
So what classical
physics tells us,
it says, in
classical physics, it
costs more energy to create
a dipole moment, or even
a fluctuating dipole
moment, than one gets back
from the dipole interaction.
So the system will
never spontaneously form
some form of dipole moment.
And in classical physics,
two neutral atoms
will have no attraction at all.
So it costs more energy.
So now, we have to
do quantum mechanics.
And every so often, I have to
go through a classical argument
to make you wonder about the
quantum mechanical result.
Because the quantum mechanical
result, you're used to it.
You've heard about the
van der Waals interaction.
But now you know
that there is really
something quantum at work.
In quantum mechanics,
the expectation value
of the square of the dipole
operator is not zero.
I mean, you can see that if
you have an electron, which
is in an harmonic
oscillator, and if it
is at the bottom of
the oscillator-- well,
the dipole moment--
what I want you to say
is the dipole moment
for a charged system
is related to-- between
electron and proton--
to the displacement operator, R.
And even if you have an
equilibrium position--
like in an harmonic oscillator,
where R is equal to zero,
R squared-- the expectation
value-- is not zero,
because whatever your
stable equilibrium is,
you will have zero point
fluctuations around it.
And so therefore, now
in quantum physics,
it's not that we have to provide
energy to create a d squared.
We have it.
We have it by necessity, because
of non-commuting operators,
because of the nature
of the quantum physics.
So now, the fact that we have
fluctuating dipole moments
already, that means if now
with the fluctuating dipole
moments between the two
atoms are synchronized,
this will then lead to a
non-vanishing average force
between the atoms.
So that's the idea.
But the good thing
is, you don't even
have to know about it-- about
fluctuations and all that.
You just take-- and
this is your homework--
you just take the
operator H prime.
And look what happens when
you have an atom in the ground
and excited state
and what happens
when you have both atoms
in the ground state.
In the first case, you
get the leading result
in first order
perturbation theory.
For two ground state atoms,
you have to go to second order.
In first order, the
potential is 1 over R cubed.
And you will calculate
the C3 coefficient.
In second order, you get
a van der Waals potential,
which is 1 over R to the sixth.
And it's fairly
straightforward to calculate
the C6 coefficient.
Any questions?
So let me reemphasize, the
beauty of this perturbation
result that it's so simple.
But the downside
is, you don't really
understand what you're doing.
I mean, you are solving
the Schrodinger equation.
You are finding an
expectation value.
But the nature of
the effect-- how
it is related to fluctuation,
what is really behind it--
is sometimes obscured.
So let me give you one
interpretation, which I really
like.
And I learned that
actually from Dan Kleppner.
When he taught the atomic
physics course at MIT
20 years ago, that
was one element of it.
And I told you at the
beginning that I'm actually
proud that our atomic
physics course is really
kind of-- has hopefully
kept-- the best of the decade
long tradition of teachers
like Norman Ramsey, Dan
Kleppner, and Dave Pritchard.
So this is now really
due to Dan Kleppner.
And I will later
today actually post
Dan Kleppner's original lecture
notes about this effect.
So we want to understand
the van der Waals
force in a completely
different system.
And I think that helps.
We have two LC circuits.
There's L, C, C, L.
And what happens is, the
two capacitors are closed.
So there is this stray field
of one capacitor reaching
the other capacitor.
So I won't go through
the detailed math here,
because it's not necessary.
But what we have
here is, we have
two coupled systems--
two coupled capacitors.
And the only thing
I want to use is
that the stray
field of a capacitor
has a diopolic characteristic.
And it decays with
1 over R cubed.
So what we have right
now is, each LC circuit,
when it's isolated, has
a resonant frequency
of omega naught.
But now, when we have two
pendulums-- two oscillators--
which are coupled,
we get two modes,
which are omega plus and minus.
And if we simply
solve for two modes,
and they have some
coupling, well, we
get an upshift and
downshift by the coupling.
But if you look more carefully
at the solution for two
coupled modes, it has
also a quadratic effect,
which is sometimes
neglected, but it's there.
So this is, in
general, what you will
find, if you couple two modes.
Now in quantum
mechanics, when we
ask for the oscillator
in the ground state,
we can find the
zero point energy.
And so the energy
in the ground state
is 1/2 the zero point
energy in the mode plus,
in the mode minus.
The first order coupling term,
the 1 over R cubed cancels out.
But what remains
is a contribution,
which is 1 over R to the sixth.
So we need quantum physics.
Because in classical
physics, the ground state
of the LC circuit
is nothing happens.
No charge, no
current, no nothing.
I mean, this is a
classical ground state,
and you would not
get any effect.
So realize that this van
der Waals potential requires
quantum mechanics, and it
is due to the zero point
energy of the
atomic oscillators.
Just hold the
thought, when we talk
about atoms in the
electromagnetic field,
we have two oscillators.
We have an harmonic
oscillator, which
is a fluctuating dipole moment
on each side of the atom.
But we have many, many harmonic
oscillators in between,
which is the
electromagnetic field.
And during the course
of this lecture,
I will refer to
both the zero point
energy of the atomic
oscillator and the zero point
energy of the oscillator, which
is the electromagnetic field.
And to give you the
result at the end,
I will sort of explain
different effects
by the zero point oscillation
of the atoms, other effects
of the electromagnetic field.
But at the end of this
section, which is probably
after spring break on
Monday, I will actually
tell you that you
have to be careful.
If you have quantum
physics, you have
to use a consistent description.
And you always need that
both the field and the atoms
are quantized and give
zero point fluctuations.
And when I'm telling you
now that the van der Waals
potential is due
only to zero point
fluctuations of the
atomic oscillator,
there may be another way
of getting the same result
by looking at the zero
point fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field.
So I just want you
to take what I'm
saying to you-- I'm not
saying to you anything wrong.
But it may not be the
only way of expressing it.
And I want you just to
pay attention to it.
But certain effects
can be simply described
by just simply looking at
the atomic oscillators.
Why do we need the quantized
electromagnetic field
when all we want to do
is have a stray field
coupling two capacitors.
So we want to always
learn about the simplest
way to understanding an effect.
But then in the end, there
are maybe certain subtleties.
OK.
But let's keep it simple.
So it's a zero point energy
of the two oscillators.
And maybe let me emphasize
this by translating
this description-- what we
learned from the capacitors.
Let me give you the Coulomb
description of the atom.
So an atom really never have in
free space a spontaneous dipole
moment.
But because of zero
point oscillation,
it will have a dipole
moment squared.
So what happens now is,
let's say at some moment,
we have a fluctuation.
One atom happens to
have a fluctuation
of the dipole moment.
This creates an electric field
at the position of the atom, b.
So this is a fluctuating field.
The fluctuating
field, because there's
a finite polarizability,
induces now
a dipole moment of the atom, db.
I will later introduced
polarizabilities.
But here, it's just
proportional to Eb.
So that's proportional
to da over R cubed.
So now, we have no longer
randomly fluctuating
dipole moments with da db,
which are out of phase.
Positive and minus cancels out.
We have a dipole
moment, da, which
creates-- through
polarizability--
an aligned dipole moment, db.
And for those, we have now
the dipole-dipole interaction,
which is db da over R cubed.
And when db changes
sign, da changes signs.
So the product of them
will always stay the same.
And now, we find that
we have an interaction.
If you look, db
was 1 over R cubed.
And if you multiply
that with the R
cubed of the
dipole-dipole interaction,
we obtain, in a
very different way,
the van der Waals potential,
which is 1 over R to the sixth.
So therefore, what
we can take away
from that is that the 1 over
R to the sixth potential
is caused by the zero
point fluctuations
of the atomic dipole moments.
OK.
So now you have already
three different ways
to look at the van
der Waals potential.
One is just doing
perturbation theory
and not understanding anything.
The second one is
the ground state
of two coupled oscillators,
a la two capacitors.
And finally, the fact that
spontaneous fluctuations create
stimulated fluctuations,
and then there
is a quadratic term,
which doesn't vanish.
OK.
Well, let's now consider that
the electromagnetic field--
that there is an
electromagnetic field.
Until now, we have not
really used the fact
that we have an electromagnetic
field with photons.
And the electromagnetic
fields, each mode,
is an harmonic oscillator.
And each mode of the
electromagnetic field
has zero point
fluctuation of itself.
So let us now discuss what
can the vacuum fluctuations
of the electromagnetic
field do for us.
Well, if we have fluctuations--
momentary fluctuations--
of the electric
field of the vacuum,
the fluctuation at position,
a, and position, b,
will induce now dipole
moments of the atoms, a and b,
by multiplying with the
atomic polarizability.
And if you assume-- I'll say
a little bit more about it--
that we're talking about
the long wavelengths
fluctuation of the
electric field.
Then the two dipole
moments, which
are induced by those
vacuum fluctuations,
are actually in phase.
So the key word is now that
the vacuum fluctuations
create correlated
dipole moments.
So the dipole moments are
no longer independently
fluctuating by themselves.
So if you write down now the
dipole-dipole interaction,
we will find a result which
is proportional to the product
of the two polarizabilities.
The dipole interaction has an
intrinsic spatial dependence,
which is 1 over R cubed.
But now, the important
term is that we
have to calculate
the correlation
function of the electric
field at position,
a, and position, b.
And these are the
vacuum fluctuations.
I'm not doing the
calculation, because it
would be somewhat messy.
I really post on the web a
fairly easy-to-read paper
by Larry Spruch
in Physics Today.
And he gives you a
little bit more details.
But you have already the
physics in this equation.
What you should use
now is, you have
to use the density of modes.
And for each mode, the zero
point energy, 1/2 h-bar omega.
And then, what you get is,
you get an interaction,
which is 1 over
R to the seventh.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you're
accounting here
only the dipole moment,
which are [INAUDIBLE].
So they're coming
from the fluctuation
of long wavelengths in your EM.
And once they [INAUDIBLE]
those but they
are EM field
fluctuation from vacuum.
So what are the effect
of those shorter waves?
Are they just higher
energies, or just--
PROFESSOR: Excellent question.
Actually, I need
that-- in 10 minutes--
I need exactly the
answer to your question.
So let me give you
the answer right now.
If you look at this
expression, there
are two things which
come into place.
One is we have now two atoms
separated by a distance, R,
which is ra minus rb .
If you take, now, high frequency
modes, which are very short
wavelengths, and you
integrate and sum over
all of them, it's pretty
clear that you will get
plus and minus, which will
completely average out.
So it seems very clear that
the modes with wavelengths,
lambda, shorter-- definitely
much shorter-- than R average
out.
So therefore, the bulk
of the contribution
will actually come from
the modes with wavelengths
smaller than R.
But now, there is
something else.
The density of states for
the electromagnetic field
dramatically increases
with frequency, omega.
So we have many more modes
at short wavelengths.
So therefore, the
argument says, well,
the long wavelength
modes, up to wavelengths,
R, are the dominant ones.
They don't average out.
But because the density
of modes increases,
the shorter the
wavelength is, by
far the dominant
contribution, will
come from the modes, which
are centered around lambda
equals R.
So the density of
modes implies now
that those modes will dominate.
So that's the answer.
But ultimately, you have to put
everything into an equation,
have an integral,
solve the integral,
do some approximation.
And you will exactly see
from the density of modes
that the very long
wavelengths don't contribute.
And you will also see that
because of rapid averaging of E
to the ikr phase factors,
the high frequency modes
will not contribute.
OK.
So we have now two
different power laws.
One is 1 over R to the sixth.
And one is 1 over
R to the seventh.
So let's explain that now.
So we obtain the 1 over R
sixth by using the uncertainty
principle for atoms.
And here, we have used the
uncertainty principle, the zero
point fluctuations for
electromagnetic waves.
When we derive the 1
over R sixth potential,
we actually used simply the
electrostatic instantaneous
Coulomb field dipole field.
And this is only valid for
short range when-- you know,
I said we have a fluctuation
and the fluctuation
created another one,
which was in phase.
But if one fluctuation
has to send out
an electromagnetic wave,
the second fluctuation
may not be in.
When propagation
effects come into play,
there's a time lag between
the two oscillators
and may actually
be out of phase.
So we really assumed
in the derivation,
without ever saying
it explicitly,
that there are no
propagation effects.
And this is called the
short range potential.
Whereas, for the second
argument that we said,
we have two distant atoms,
which get synchronized
by being driven by fluctuations
of the electromagnetic wave
at wavelengths,
lambda equals R. This
is what happens at long range.
So this is a famous result,
that we have a van der Waals
force, which is the
instantaneous force.
And when propagation
effects come into play,
this goes by the name
Casimir-Polder potential.
The moment when propagation
effects come into play--
when radiation plays a role--
we get a different power law.
So again, I'm just
playing with ideas.
I'm taking a train
of thought, atoms
fluctuate; another train of
thought, electromagnetic fields
propagate; and just see,
what are the ramifications?
What are the consequences?
So now, I want to
eventually give you
a treatment, which has
both aspects in one.
And this is our
diagrammatic treatment.
First, before I do
with that, do you
have any idea what
distinguishes the short range
from the long range potential?
So you have two atoms.
You pull them apart.
And what distance do we have the
1 over R to the sixth physics?
At what distance do
you have the 1 over R
to the seventh physics?
AUDIENCE: When
[INAUDIBLE] transitions?
PROFESSOR: When the
distance is the wavelengths
of the atomic transition.
That's the only
thing which matters.
You don't get it
immediately from here.
Because-- I mean, I used
an instantaneous potential,
which didn't have any scale.
And here, I said we
have vacuum fluctuations
of all wavelengths.
So here, I had a
picture, which clearly
works at long separation.
And propagation
effects are built in,
because it's a vacuum
fluctuation, which
sort of act at
position, a and b.
And the wavelengths--
their propagation--
is part of the formulation.
But yes, Bohr's
conjecture that it
is the wavelengths of the
atom-- the wavelengths
of the resonant
radiation-- is correct.
But I want to show
you now how we
can obtain this
result in a, I think,
really elegant and
beautiful way by looking
at the diagrams we
have just learned.
OK.
What did we just have?
Time to do that, yes.
Any questions here?
The reason why I want to
show it diagrammatically
is actually two fold.
One is, it's really
beautiful how it comes out.
But the second thing is, when I
introduced the Feynman diagrams
and all of these formulation
in terms of propagators,
I gave you a wonderful picture.
But in the end, I reduced
it to first and second order
perturbation theory.
So I want to show you at
least one nontrivial example
where you would not
get the result easily
without this formalism.
So enjoy one nontrivial
application of diagrams.
So if you follow the systematic
way, how we have set up
our formulation of
quantum electrodynamic
with a photon field-- the
quantized photon field--
then the two neutral atoms have
no direct Coulomb interaction.
I just want to point that out.
Because a few
minutes ago, when I
said a classical system is just
Coulomb field-- each charge
element has a Coulomb potential
with the other charge element--
this was just the
opposite approach.
But in our QED formulation,
we have sold our soul.
We have said we only
really got the near field,
the longitudinal field,
as belonging to the atoms.
Everything which
happens at longer range
is included in our
atom-photon Hamiltonian.
So therefore, there is no
direct Coulomb interaction
for the longitudinal field.
Everything, everything now, has
to come from the interaction--
the perturbation operator-- for
the quantized radiation field.
And therefore, we
must get it out.
We have one atom;
it's d1 at d prime.
I think that's how it's-- I'm
using now the nomenclature,
which is used in atom-photon
interaction, pages 121 to 126.
And so, there is one atom
at the unprimed location,
one atom at the time
primed location.
And everything has
to come out now
of the formulation of the
quantized radiation field.
And we have discussed
that lengths
at the transverse electric
field become operators,
a plus a dagger-- the symbol
for the dipole operators
are acting on the atoms.
We've done all that.
So then the only thing
which happens is--
and this is described
by a and a dagger--
is the exchange of photons.
So the only way how those two
neutral objects can interact
is through the radiation field.
And through the
radiation field means
they have to emit photons.
So I want to show you now
that the van der Waals
interaction can be thought of
as one atom emitting a photon.
But this virtual
photon is absorbed
by the other atom
and vice versa.
And you may have
heard quite often--
but I'm not sure if you've
seen it explicitly--
that a lot of
interactions in physics
are actually mediated by the
exchange of virtual particles.
The famous example is
that the nuclear force
comes from a virtual
exchange of pions.
But then, people say,
the Coulomb force
comes from a virtual
exchange of photons.
But usually, we
don't really show you
how this virtual
exchange of photons work.
So in that sense,
I'm proud that I
can show you, at least
the basic outline, how
virtual exchange of photons
between two neutral atoms
leads to the van
der Waals potential.
So that's our agenda.
OK.
Now the fact that this takes
six pages in the book--
and the book is not
solving all equations--
means if you really want
to do it quantitatively,
it has a certain complexity.
But what I've done is, I've sort
of distilled out the grand idea
and which also shows
you what happens
when you go from short
range to long range.
And this is what I
want to present you.
And therefore, I take
[? Benji's ?] question
and will not discuss
all the modes
of the electromagnetic field.
I will immediately use the fact
that the dominant contribution
comes from modes.
And since we don't
have real photons,
we don't have energy to create
real photons when everything
is in the current state.
We call them virtual photons.
Virtual photons are photons
which are immediate.
But a short time later, because
of Heisenberg uncertainty,
have to disappear.
So the dominant contribution
comes from virtual photons
at the wavelengths, which is
D, the distance between atoms.
So the frequency, which
will play an important role,
is simply the frequency
of those virtual photons.
And I gave you already the
reason-- the density of states
which favor higher frequencies.
But higher frequencies
cancel, because of the E
to the ikr terms.
So we only focus on those.
The second thing I
need is that when
we do perturbation theory, the
energy shift in perturbation
theory-- well, if
you do second order,
you go from the initial state
to an intermediate state.
And then, you go from the
intermediate state, one,
to the final state.
And what you have
to do is, you have
to divide by the
energy denominator.
If you do higher and higher
order perturbation theory,
in our diagrammatic
presentation,
that means we have propagators
at intermediate energies.
And I told you that
the time an atom can
spend in an intermediate state
is 1 over the energy defect.
And if you integrate the
E to the i energy defect
factor over time,
you get something
which is proportional
to 1 over delta E.
So therefore, if you
perform the time integration
of the perturbation
analysis, you
find by integrating over the
short time particles spend
in the intermediate
state, you actually
generate those
energy denominators.
That's actually the relationship
between the time propagation
I showed you earlier.
And when you integrate
over the time,
you get for this intermediate
state, a contribution,
which is 1 over
the energy defect
over the intermediate state.
So therefore, if you go now
to higher order perturbation
theory, we simply have a
product of matrix elements
in the numerator.
And in the denominator, we have
a product of energy defects.
You are using that all the time
for second order perturbation
theory, but the structure
is that you can just
sort of daisy chain
the expression.
And you get higher order
perturbation theory.
So therefore, all we will have
to understand to figure out
what happens when virtual
photons are exchanged,
I will just show you
two relevant diagrams.
And we just look-- we
stare at the diagrams--
and figure out what
are these denominators?
What are those energy defects?
And we will find that
there's a difference
at long range and short range.
So that's the agenda.
So we will need two energies.
One energy is the energy
of the virtual photon,
which is exchanged.
And the second
energy, or frequency,
is the resonant
frequency of the atom.
So let's look at two
relevant diagrams.
So one is atom,
a; one is atom, b.
We are interested
in interactions
between atoms in
the ground state.
And after a
sufficiently long time,
both atoms have to be
back in the ground state.
Let me just get this organized,
one, two, three, four.
And the result is obtained
in fourth order perturbation
theory.
It has to be fourth
order, because we
need photon exchange.
To emit a photon here, absorb
it here, is second order.
But then, one atom is
in the excited state
and this can't be.
So a second photon is
required to undo the effect.
So we need exchange
of photon pairs.
Each exchange means
absorption and emission.
That means two vertices.
And photon pairs
means another two.
So we need fourth order
perturbation theory.
OK.
But it's much, much
easier than you think.
So we have a ground state atom.
And now the action starts.
This is the first vertex.
It emits a photon.
The photon is absorbed
by the other atom, which
puts the atom into
the excited state.
This atom is also in the
excited state, of course.
And then, we know the atom
cannot stay in the excited
state for a long time.
It can now emit a second
photon, which brings it back
to the ground state.
And the second photon
is absorbed by atom, b,
and puts the atom back
into the ground state.
So this is one relevant diagram.
And let me analyze it
in the energy defects.
Here, in the first
intermediate step,
the energy defect is--
well, we have ground-ground.
This is sort our reference.
But now, we have put one
atom into the excited state.
That causes energy,
omega naught.
And we have created
one photon, omega.
Here in that time step,
there are no photons,
but there are two excited atoms.
And in the third time step,
we have still one atom
in the excited state
and one photon.
Now, this is one relevant class.
I mean, you can now use
permutations at atom, b,
excites photons first and such.
But the structure of
many of these diagrams
will be the same that we have
those three energy defects.
But now, we have
another possibility.
And this is, one
atom emits a photon,
but it feels it doesn't
want to be excited,
because the excitation
energy is so precious.
It wants to immediately
return to the ground state.
So we could have a situation
that the atom fires
a second photon before the
first photon is absorbed.
So the diagram-- the relevant
diagram-- is now this.
So the atom started
in the ground state,
is in the excited state,
but as soon as possible,
goes back to the ground state.
And the other atom starts
out in ground state,
is in the excited state, and
is back in the ground state.
So what we have here is, we have
again three intermediate steps.
In the first step, of course,
we have an excited atom
and a photon.
And we have the same here.
But now the difference is,
that in the intermediate step,
our energy defect is not
two atomic excitations,
it is two photonic excitations.
And now we want to
compare those two diagrams
for short and for long range.
And it becomes clear
that short range
is where the frequency
of the photon--
its wavelength is lambda.
Short range means
high frequency.
The frequency of
the photon is larger
than the atomic
excitation energy.
Or that means, the
distance is smaller
than the resonant
wavelength of the photon.
Whereas, long range is
that the atomic excitation
is more precious than
the photonic excitation.
OK.
So I need three more minutes.
So it just fits
into the class time.
So we are here in
the limit that omega
is larger than omega naught.
So that means, if we take now
the product of the three energy
denominators, omega
dominates over omega naught.
So we'll have this structure
omega, omega naught, omega.
Omega, omega naught, omega.
Whereas, at long range,
omega naught dominates.
We have omega naught,
omega naught, omega naught.
So the structure of the
product of energy denominators
is 1 over omega naught.
If you look on the
right hand side,
we have replaced-- in
the intermediate part
in the propagator-- the
energy defect by omega naught
by omega.
So therefore, in this case,
we have 1 over omega cubed
and 1 over omega
naught squared, omega.
So we know that when we
sum up over diagrams,
we have to sum up over
all possibly diagrams.
And the ones which dominate
at short range are those ones
and at long range
are the other ones.
So in other words,
at short range,
one photon is exchanged
and disappears.
And then, the next photon comes.
But at long range,
we have an exchange
that one atom sends out two
photons almost simultaneously.
And the other atom absorbs them.
Because it sends them out
almost simultaneously.
Because here, we are talking
about long wavelength photons,
and photons are cheaper.
Rather send out two photons
before you spend too much time
in the excited state.
OK.
Let's wrap it up.
Since omega is proportional
to 1 over the wavelengths,
which was-- and I said the
photons we are concentrating,
is the photons which have a
wavelength of the distance, D .
So what we are realizing
now is that, if you just
compare those diagrams
at long range,
we go from 1 over omega
squared to 1 over omega.
So at long range-- omega is--
we have an additional factor
of omega, which is 1 over D.
And so now, if you
assume-- I can't show you
that without solving
the real problem--
but if you assume
that at short range,
we have 1 over R to the sixth--
van der Waals potential--
then at least, I've proven
to you that at long range,
you get one more
power in the distance.
And this is a transition from an
instantaneous potential, where
propagation effects
do not matter,
to what is called
retarded potential.
So that's all I
wanted to show you
about interactions
between two neutral atoms.
Are there any questions?
Timor?
AUDIENCE: Does it matter the
direction of both the photons
that we drew?
For example, can
atom, a, emit to b, b
absorbs, and b emits
to a, rather than--
PROFESSOR: In
practice, it matters.
When you solve it, you have
to sum over all possibilities.
Remember, quantum mechanics
in the system does everything.
It doesn't care whether
it's allowed or not.
It tries everything out, whether
it violates energy or not.
And you have to sum
over everything.
But if you then analyze
all the possible diagrams,
you will actually figure out
that they can-- no matter
what you do, what permutation
of photons and atoms you
have-- the fourth order
diagrams will be such
that they are
always distinguished
by in this intermediate
zone, whether you have
two atomic excitations
or photonic excitations.
And so what I do for you
were the two diagrams,
which are representative for a
whole class of diagrams here.
But absolutely,
yes, you are right.
OK.
So that's all about
neutral atoms.
I know you have spring break
next week-- MIT spring break.
Maybe that's good news
for the Harvard people,
who-- when is
Harvard's spring break?
AUDIENCE: We just finished.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you have-- at
least for this class,
you have a second spring break.
So we are not yet finished
with van der Waals and passing
interactions, but we
finished the neutral atoms.
And on Monday
after spring break,
we talk about interactions
between metal plate
and atoms in two metal plates.